Goddammit
*speaking in dinosaur*
Ainsley! I need
*Suspense music*
....I'm out of ideas. Again
I could just come up with an idea, but that would be ridiculous
when I can just do whatever is popular!
Alright let's see what cancer is in the recommended tab
(video) NO!  NO! how did I get that wrong?!
*reads title*
that seems to be a a thing that's going on
just add a percentage of a fail
I think I' ll add
that on all my videos from now on (im surprised he didnt already do it)
the fail represents how many people
would actually watch this video
past three seconds
let's see if we can do it
(video) "Oh ma god"
"It's so easy to see now"
"enter this month's one hundred $ gift card giveaway" (lies)
nine seconds. hey! that's longer than I thought
(video) "enter this month's one hundred $ gift card giveaway" (pls dont)
"all you have to do"
Let me guess
Leave a like
"leave a like"
subscribe
"subscribe"
sell soul to Satan
"turn notifications on"
oh shit okay all right don't forget
about the notification!
Have you belled my channel yet by the way? (you should)
hey pewdiepie, you always make fun of other youtubers
you don't understand
you don't understand x2
there's so much fucking shit on youtube these days
I have to
it is my job
it is my duty at this point
to call the shit out...
I don't even care...
do you think I actually care?
no, I do not
"And if you want even more stuff check the description down below...
...for an extra giveaway"
there's more
there is more
are you telling me there is more?
I gotta check the description for more
*Fails*
whut?
it's not even available
you lied
you lied to me
DISAPPOINTED
DISAPPOINTED x2
why is this the state of YouTube?
that what whoever gets the best thumbnail
and a long ass video and you're fine
it's all these pimply ass teenagers
okay
just go away, just go, no one likes you
okay?
you need to be moderately attractive like jacksepticeye and
markiplier otherwise...
GET OUT
What we're taking a look at are some mind tricks so
good luck woah woah woah woah woah
woah an original thought just came to
my mind I'm going to make hardest
mind-trick test 99 percent fail around
ok let's do this together try not to get
mind-tricked challenge only ninety-nine
percent can beat it are you part of the
one percent? let's play along!
take a look at the image below what do
you see I see a man grasping a woman's
tits i see a nice a nice water bottle
and inside two ghosts are fucking each
other
focus on the following picture and give a
quick answer which stairs will you use
to go up and which will go down
doesn't matter it's not you that's it
that's the thing about stairs you can go
up and you can go down them i know
it's crazy
my mind is blown right now Jesus Christ
are you telling me
are you telling me that there's an equal
amount of stairs going up as there is
stairs going down
no fockin way no fockin no fockin way
I refuse I refuse to
there's a man's head somewhere in this
picture
find him
I don't even want to say it because i'm
so offended
this one is cool i really like this one
because for me right now she's going
clockwise
what about you guys I really like this
one if you really focus you can make her
change direction while you're looking at
it always remember
your focus determines your reality oh
she spins she spins in the other direction now
I looked at the head oh now she spins back
what the fuck now she's spining what's
happening (sounds of amazement)
dude this is so freaky
fuck man the brain is a weird thing
that's the that's mind blowing to me
that's so weird
fuck that's weird that one is really
good you know what that one blows my
mind every time
squirtle squirrel turtle
*mind blown*
Oh he's a squirtle *still amazed*
let's get into some real mind-blowing
business 911 predictions coming soon huh
coming soon Johnny Bravo
it started with johnny bravo this is the gastone
that French cartoon my god it was in
(weird french) there was a book cover in 1980
oh my god are those people jump- what
the fuck the Simpson of course
predicted it Lisa Simpson New York nine
dollars
it was an inside job even the Simpson was
involved 911 terrorist new
play this card at any time to get plus
10 power or resistance to any violent
what kind of game is this and even the
pentagon oh my gosh i need that game
this the 1994 iron man cartoon shows 911
Twin Towers & Pentagon hit by planes
oh my god scary word
oh my god I'm scared
I can't believe it I can't believe i
it- okay
by the way this music is not edited in
this is the actual video reme- what is that
is that a cipher reme oh reme remember
remember of course remember 9 equals
equals what oh 911
q 33 n means airplane paper paper
death my god vision test normal vision
people will see Albert Einstein and
in the picture near sighted people will see
Marilyn Monroe I don't
woah woah woah if i do this i see
Marilyn I'm not kidding i'm seeing Marilyn
right fucking now do this
i'm not kidding that's fucking cool mind equals blown
you get nine dots
oh my god nine dots what the fuck i can't
Wolverine or two bat-
they're making out batman would never
make out with himself oh just six hours ago
the Simpson predicted ladygaga yeah because artists
is never ever you know go on a zip line
or whatever it's called
no fuckin way no fuckin way no fuckin
way
that's incredible that's incredible huh
professor Frank also showed his
delight as he wrote *whispers* boobs on his calculator oh my god only
ninety eight percent of people that
watched that notice that and the rest of
the two-percent just wanted to die a
painful death
I wanna die (don't we all) what happens to a can of food
when you put it in lava a question that
of course everyone wants to know and my
mind is blown a can of Monster in lava
wow wow this is the kind of content that
has just taken over YouTube because it
asked a question and you have to click
it to get the answer i mean i know
that's literally the definition of
clicks but it but it's like what you
every time you find out the answer it
every time the reaction is like what
will happen if you let a really hot
knife into some other shit
buzzfeed is challenging me right now
can you make it through this post
without having your mind blown
put your finger in your ear and scratch
oh haha eating Cheetos with chopsticks
keep your fingers clean buzzfeed just
die already
who writes this fucking shit who who
Dave stopera listen to your last name
ok just listen to your last name has
your mind been blown
in this video then you have to leave a
like has your mind not been blown in
this video then you have to leave two
likes
also don't forget my giveaway it's in
the description
all you have to do you have to like this
video you have to bell me you have to
comment you have to facebook twitter
tumblr you have to shave your head
thank you it's been my pleasure check it
also check out this video and I'll see
you on next next one that we do